hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is what's on my android phone 2013
now I did one of these in 2012 just one
of these and apparently you guys wanted
to see a bit of an updated version of
that since it's been a while since I did
that previous video so this is a current
snapshot of my phone situation going on
here it happens to be Android still
right now and there are a whole lot of
things that are probably different about
my phone situation than about years so
I'll go ahead and details those right
now because there are a few disclaimers
that I have to get out the way before we
go to the tour so the big disclaimer is
I don't really have a daily driver that
is probably the most frequently used
word in my inbox hey what's your daily
driver and for most people that's the
the one phone that you use every single
day I don't really have one I have two
phone lines because I do review phones
one is a Verizon line and one is a
straight talk line with AT&T service the
verizon line is the one that everyone
knows and calls me by so I guess has the
closest thing to a daily driver but I
sometimes just really preferred the
phone that I'm using with AT&T that said
right now I'm using a Galaxy S 4 on
Verizon and my AT&T line is right now
it's usually in the HTC One while I
sometimes go to the Apple fly-in 5 but
when you talk about daily driver it
really just depends on the day sometimes
I go on a road trip and I don't bring a
charger with me and I just bring my
verizon Galaxy Note 2 because that's
just what lasts the longest and I don't
really have to worry about charging or
battery or anything like that so my
phone depends on the situation but I'm
going to go ahead and give you guys a
tour of my galaxy s4 so without any
further ado let's take a look alright so
this is of course the phone that we're
talking about here it's the Verizon
black galaxy s4 of course they have a
gorgeous 1080p display here for the demo
but basically I'll try to include every
single link for all the apps that I
talked about by name right below the
like button in the description so I'll
have Play Store links to everything that
you want to check out if you want to
check out these apps for yourself so
basically the setup we have going on
here is the basic treatment that I give
all the new phones that I have to test
or review or what-have-you and this is
this is basically what I'll do with
every single one of the
so I'll install this basic suite of apps
and give it this overall look so without
any further ado this is of course
Android 4.2 on the galaxy s4 so we have
our beautiful lockscreen and this is -
clock which is the widget here and of
course we have Google now to the left we
can have as many pages as we want and I
have the tasks extension I have eye on
the sky and sliding messaging Pro those
are the extensions I have for - clock so
go ahead and jump right in here and you
can see this wallpaper I've gotten a lot
of questions about this wallpaper
this wallpaper comes from the Starck
icon pack so if you download it install
the start icon pack from the Google Play
Store and you select a wallpaper you'll
have the ability to select this one from
the start icon pack so this is pretty
sweet you should also follow me on
Twitter by the way that link will be on
top of the description anyway this is
action launcher pro and this is why I
have all my apps to the side of the
launcher here sort of gone along with
the Android design language of being
able to swipe in from the side this is
now in my launcher as well so this is
action launcher pro and again I have a
full-screen dash clock widget for all my
information here and of course I can
change any of the settings here if I
ever want to do that and I have two
pages so one is my - clock fullscreen
widget and right beside that is my most
frequently used apps those are the
frequently used apps so I have Google
keep Google Play Music I in the sky
feedly and Google Plus
on the sky is the weather app it's a
pretty great app and it's also a
beautiful day outside
feedly since a Google Reader is dying
pretty soon we have feebly to keep track
of all that's happening in the world
Google Plus you should totally +1 this
if you're following me here Google Plus
is pretty much the greatest thing to
come out of Google anyway YouTube the
new YouTube app came out today which
allows you to swipe in from the side
from anywhere in the app just a neat
little thing Google Maps Instagram
gallery jb+
which is where I have all my pictures
obviously I don't use the stock gallery
it tends to be pretty terrible and the
galaxy s4 and s3 and also WolframAlpha a
very underrated app of course you got to
know how many vitamins are in your bacon
but yeah this is the most frequently
used app section down at the bottom I
have Google now Google Tasks Falcon
which is the Twitter app of choice for
me
of course if you want to follow me there
like I said the link is below sliding
messaging I don't want to show you guys
that and Google Calendar which is of
course Google Calendar so of course I'll
swipe into the side I'm going to show
you the list of all the apps I have here
you can always bring in widgets if you
want from this particular list but I
have a couple of games not really all
that many camera jb+ is basically the
stock camera with your camera app from
Android 4.2 jelly bean so that's nice to
have Amazon chrome clock jb+ is the
stock clock app of course so again I'm
getting a lot of things from jelly bean
here contacts and dialer are some
third-party apps I have to replace the
very ugly Samsung ones dirt road
structure 3d has been a addiction of
mine recently Google Drive Dropbox ebay
eye on the sky Facebook Falcon
blahblahblah one over is already halo is
for hailing taxis in New York City which
is neat
hangouts of course hollow calc it's just
a neat looking calculator it looks a
thousand billion times better than
Samsung's calculators so I'll basically
use this one every time I need to do
something at the calculator Google keep
of course Instagram if you want to
follow me on Instagram my name on every
social network is mkbhd so can't miss
that maps facebook Messenger so of
course we get our chat heads going on
there MightyText is what allows me to
sync and send texts from my computer so
that's pretty useful too and then a
whole bunch of other things package
buddy lets me track any package I get a
lot of packages and also send a lot so
that's definitely helpful for
maintaining that sort of information a
whole bunch of playthings pocket very
useful reddit news is my reddit app of
choice
SkyDrive for golfing Snapseed for photo
editing SoundCloud for music listening
speed view is a way to see you're
basically a speedometer via GPS I was in
a train one day I wanted to know how
fast I was going so I just opened the
app and it gave me my exact speed in
miles per hour so that was pretty useful
and I had a pretty accurate real-time
reading of that so that was cool and
that's almost it we're getting to the
end here Spotify the stark eye contact
of course tasks Tetris The Weather
Channel translate vine I just signed up
for vine I don't think I'm going to use
it but somehow I have a thousand follow
there so maybe I'll have to do some
vines and then WolframAlpha and YouTube
that's basically it so there is my
current galaxy s4 setup if you guys were
wondering all of these links like I said
I'll try to include in the description
below this is in fact a Play Store link
by the way and action launcher also
happens to have a quick little search so
if I want to search for say Google+ or I
don't have Google+ by PL but the Play
Store or anything it'll be able to open
an app just for that little quick search
box so that's your usefull button of the
day
either way notification bar of course
this annoying Wi-Fi notification from
all the Verizon phones but also this
empty in 14 hours this is from battery
widget reborn so that's telling me how
much battery life I have left in percent
and then tells me exactly how much time
left and then of course a go ahead
little torch here to show I don't know I
light up my whatever whenever I need to
get into a place that's dark and I don't
have a flashlight so there you go that's
the Android setup of mkbhd for 2013 so
there you go that has been what's on my
Android phone 2013 again it's been
Android for the past two times that I've
done this video if you have a way to
personalize a Windows Phone or an iPhone
or a blackberry surprise me you leave it
as a video response usually you can tell
from a mile away when someone's using an
iPhone and usually you can tell from
pretty far away when it's a Windows
Phone or a blackberry but if you have no
idea what's going on with someone's
phone
chances are it's an Android phone so go
ahead and leave your video responses
below if you want to leave a tour of
your setup and I'll be checking it out
giving some ideas getting some ideas and
I'll definitely some comments on those
either way leave a thumbs up if you
enjoyed thank you for watching and I'll
talk
in the next video